yeah so ezra miller they're back in the  news again  apparently now they've been charged with  burglary uh this stems from an incident  that happened back at the start of may  in stamford vermont vermont police were  actually able to locate miller and serve  them with notice that they are to appear  in court on september 26th  yeah we'll see if they actually show up  for that sort of the weird thing about  that is that i could not find any  confirmation that they were also served  with all the other stuff that's been  waiting for them you know the protective  orders and all that um but  i guess vermont  police aren't  the jurisdiction to serve them with that  so maybe that's still pending i don't  know i don't know this just gets added  to the pile i  it's not gonna stop is it this holds  just gonna keep  i've had enough